well the nato military alliance oversaw
the 20-year intervention in afghanistan
involving more than 30 countries but it
was forced to end the mission when the
u.s announced unilaterally that it was
withdrawing its troops many are now
wondering how the chaotic withdrawal
will affect the future of the alliance
former nato secretary general lord
robertson says he was proud to invoke
article 5 mutual defense to support
washington after 9 11 the only time it's
been used but now robertson blasts
nato's full withdrawal also compelled by
the u.s
i don't feel proud i feel ashamed
because that solidarity seems to have
gone the principle of we all go in
together and we all come out together
seems to have been completely lost
foreign ministers meeting in emergency
session last week focused first on the
evacuation crisis but also tasked
secretary general jens stoltenberg with
launching a review into what happened in
afghanistan and what consequences it
might have for nato the main problem is
uh the suffering of the afghan people
then this is also difficult for nato
there's no doubt about that and that's
the reason why we need to be honest and
be clear-eyed
and ask those hard questions about what
are the lessons learned stoltenberg
primarily blames the afghan government
and armed forces for failing to repel
the taliban advance but others say
there's plenty of responsibility to go
around starting with the west's overly
ambitious intentions to fundamentally
change afghanistan
doug lute is a retired u.s general who
served in afghanistan as well as an
ambassador to nato and a white house
advisor on afghan policy he says one big
mistake the military alliance made
ironically was its focus on the military
fight
afghanistan collapsed our government in
afghanistan collapsed
not because of military failure
where we had put all this focus but
because of the politics but others will
be drawing conclusions from nato's
actions as well afghan women who made
massive gains in equality with the
support of the international community
and the taliban which appears to feel
entitled to bully half the population
back into burkas in constant fear
despite pledges not to do so women's
rights activists wonder how nato will
assess this part of its record in
afghanistan i do not know how i would
look these women and girls in the eye
and say we we made a promise we came
here we take we said we will protect you
we will be here for you be brave be bold
be courageous and now that you became
that we just left you in the mouth of
the taliban in the hands of the taliban
now they now
they will treat you as their life and we
don't care about that anymore
hassan now no longer spends her days
helping afghan women get jobs but
pleading with nato governments to help
them escape
we can take a closer look at this with
lakhdar brahimi who was a u.n a special
representative to afghanistan and played
a key role in setting up the interim
government that followed the tap the
toppling of the taliban in 2001. he's
also a member of the elders a group of
world leaders helping to secure a peace
welcome to uh dw um
as someone who has invested so much time
in trying to bring peace to afghanistan
i wonder
can you understand
joe biden's position that in giving a
hard
deadline to withdraw his troops from
afghanistan
uh you know i i don't think it is right
it will be right for me to judge
what people are doing now because i'm
not involved anymore i'm very far i try
to follow what is happening
and i would like to talk about
afghanistan and the people of
afghanistan rather than
i'm sure you'll have ample time to do
your postmartem
about what uh the west has done there
uh let's talk about uh
afghanistan well let's let's do that
then uh and and
let's talk first of all of all though
about about about you as someone who has
invested so much time in trying to bring
peace when you heard that the taliban
was back
what went through your mind
uh well what has been through my mind is
that this is uh this was predictable and
uh
you know we all everyone made lots of
mistakes right from the beginning
and
we really never really stopped
to look back
and
criticize ourselves
uh
you know i think you know two
two important documents
uh
you know date back to my time at the
very beginning you know the petersburg
and by the way you know we are extremely
grateful to germany for their
hospitality their interests their
support at that time
so the the the document that allowed us
to start
you know the
the implementation of the pittsburgh
document
and the other thing is some something i
have distributed in the middle of 2003
inviting everybody to sit down
i called it the bond two non-paper born
two
and let's go back to a new conference of
one
and
look at what we have done we've done a
lot of very good things
uh but we made mistakes and it is time
to review what where we are going right
and what do you think the biggest
mistakes were
well one of the biggest probably one of
the biggest mistakes is that when we
went back to kabul
people now talk about the fact that we
didn't invite the taliban to born it was
impossible to invite the taliban to born
and they wouldn't have come they had
just been beaten uh routed uh sent to or
you know out of all the cities that they
were controlling
the coming to one was was not was
nothing was not an option
but
when we came back we didn't ask
ourselves a very simple question
the taliban have been routed they have
been out of the cities
where have they gone what are they
thinking
isn't it time that we we try send
fillers out to see
uh
and and see perhaps we can talk to them
to some of them at least we didn't do
that okay
and you see they represented they
represented something in afghanistan in
those days
and you know like
what afghans are they don't give up
they were they they they suffered the
defeat but they don't they didn't think
that they lost the war okay so looking
ahead then um
the un's humanitarian mandate in
afghanistan expires in september
what do you think the un should do
should it seek to renew it with a
taliban-run government
absolutely
absolutely the u.n cannot leave a place
like afghanistan
and the u.n should be in the business of
talking to everybody not only to the
good guys
you know
the good guys don't need the uh they can
solve their problems alone
we should be in the business of talking
to everybody
and now the taliban is a very important
player
not only in afghanistan but in the
entire region
the iranians are talking to them the
chinese are talking to them the
russians are talking to them in addition
to pakistan of course where their
their lives uh so you are i mean that's
a very important player in there
understand the religion you don't like
them or you don't you have got to talk
to them thank you so much for joining us
and outlining that so clearly lakhdar
brahimi thank you
thank you very much